hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com had to make a video
because the entire chess world right now
is talking about the fact that magnus
carlsen
just lost his first game in over two
years
at least classical game he's definitely
lost a rapid or blitz game when you
think of time control classical being
more of the games lasting a couple hours
and blitz and rapid being more of you're
counting it in minutes
but lost his first classical game in
over two years 125
game streak 42 wins 83 draws
no one's beating madness carlsen since
july of 2018 bobby fischer's longest
streak was 20 games just to give you
some context of
how amazing this was for magnus carlsen
longest streak out there
for a player magnus carlson world
champion
you know he's playing the best of the
best and to not lose for two years is
crazy but
at the norway chess tournament going on
right now hometown
home country at least from magnus
carlson loses to young christoph duda 22
year old
player from poland and he has been
phenomenal lately over the past
year and a half just climbed by the
rankings almost cracking into the top
ten we'll see how he finishes in this
tournament
but just played an amazing game today
with the white pieces to give magnus
cross in
first defeat in over two years and
afterwards john kristoff said he didn't
even think he played that well thought
he made a lot of mistakes
but was fortunate enough to get the win
magnus crosston fought to the very end
but jan kristoff earned the victory so i
thought we'd go ahead and go over
that game today
dude starts out with e4 and then c6
d4 then we get into the car con that's
something we expected from magnus
carlsen knight to c3
see the exchange here on e4 and after
knight f6
knight takes here on f6 pawn captures
here on f6
kind of the old theory was to take with
your g-pawn
but kind of modern theory says to go and
just take here
yes white's going to have a better pawn
structure but this does open up for some
rapid development from black so it's
fine
since black has the bishop pair here
c3 and then a bishop to d6 preparing to
castle on the king side
bishop to d3 has some options as well to
castle on the kings side at some point
castle and then queen to ct c
two so the queen and the bishop both
attacking the pawn here on h7
black has a couple options could play f5
could play g6 uh could play h6 h5
decides first for an in-between move of
rook to e8 you're gonna do it at some
point but this is jack so
buys you a move here uh knight to e2
and then h5 is the move from madness
carlson and the pawns over here if you
kind of look at it
they're protecting a lot of these
g-square so
g6 g5 and g4 all protected by the pawns
over here so another reason that you
would
take with your e-pawn here does allow
you to just protect more of the squares
that young kristoff may be looking to
attack here
bishop to e3 now has a couple options
here could castle on the king side or
the queen side knight to d7 and then
castle on
the queen side b5 bobby fischer soon as
castles on the queen side starts to
attack here
and then white plays the move
d5 now what's interesting about this is
afterwards they're obviously
interviewing the players and they ask
you on kristoff you know
this took you about 20 minutes
and he said yeah i was really trying to
figure out you know all the calculations
once the pontics here because there's a
couple options you know you could have
the bishop just takes here on b5 so
that's one you could have
bishop to h7 and then depending on where
the king moves maybe king 2 h8
this bishop still protected but then you
have rook takes here on
uh d5 and so he was just playing all
those different scenarios of what
happens once magnus carlsen takes
here on d5 and as soon as he plays d5
remember he thought about this for 20
minutes manny's carlson immediately
played
c5 and he's like okay well that was not
what i was expecting at all
uh decided to go and take with his
bishop here on b5 spanish crossing
giving up
some material for a very very strong
attack rook here to
b8 attacking this bishop
pawn to c4 and then a6 now the the
commentators on the game you have you
know kromnic and svidler you know two of
the top players
uh to play the game they thought magnus
carlson would actually play
rook takes here on e3 and after
the pawn takes to then knight to e5
great outpost in the center of the board
and they say
uh while black is down material it's
very difficult for white to actually
find compensation and you know it's
it's a pretty good position for black
here that's not what magnus carlsen
decided to do instead plays
a6 here bishop comes back to a4
and then rook to e7 now in this
variation
uh you know you can go back in the
database and see when this has been
played at top level
before this rook 2 e5 was really
the play uh rook to e7 is a novel move
that magnus carlsen seemed that he had
prepared for this
and the idea is that after knight two g3
knight to e5 great outpost as we talked
about
then the rook can come over to b7
semi-open file start to double up and
really attack
this queen side for white
now we see e4 from white rook over here
to
b7 b3 was looking at some other options
like queen to
c3 but at the end decided just go ahead
and solidify the pawn chain
with b3 and then rook b4
and duda said he was not expecting this
uh at all for magnus carlson he was
really expecting bishop here to
f5 and said he didn't even know how to
respond correctly
because he really didn't like f3 so was
pleasantly surprised once he saw
rook to b4 bishop to
d2 attacking the rook and magnus carlson
says yeah i'll just continue to give up
material
because i have a very strong attack so
trades the rook off for the bishop here
now the double pawns on the a file it's
going to be difficult for
white to hold on to this magnus carlsen
should be able to get that material back
but you know giving up that rook
that's a lot of material that magnus
carlsen is giving up does still have
the bishop pair here brings the bishop
down to f5
we have rook to e1 protecting the knight
also just giving some
air for the king to move if he needs to
pawn two h4 pawn up here to h3
uh difficult to see exactly how magnus
carlsen should continue here
obviously has given up some material so
wants to keep the pressure on
uh some of the thoughts that the the
commentators had were maybe knight to g4
trying to add more pressure h4
doesn't seem to put too much pressure on
white seemed pretty fine just playing h3
stopping that attack here
knight comes back here to g6 rook to e3
knight down here to f4 trying to attack
as much as possible pawn up here to
g4 attacking the bishop bishop swings
back to
g6 and then king to a d1 if you look at
this knight here on f4
it's kind of a nuisance it can come to
all these awkward squares at some point
check the king so uh duda just decides
go ahead and play king 2
d1 uh stop all of those threats
f5 here knight takes the
bishop here on d6 and after the queen
takes pawn to
f5 uh bishop to
h5 uh check and then you have f3
stopping that attack you can see madness
carlson with the pieces he has left and
really trying to apply pressure knowing
that he's down
in material and if as they continue to
trade off pieces it's not going to go
good for
madness carlson magnus continues with
queen
to f6 and then bishop c3 attacking the
queen
queen g5 queen up here to e4 and duda
said yeah i should just play to rook to
e1
uh did not like the queen to e4 but
plays queen to e4
queen down here g2 and then rook e1 you
can see the queen rook and rook
all along this e file getting ready to
attack
the king here queen takes here at a2 but
really it just
isolates the queen over here probably
not the best move for madness carlson
tough to get all of his pieces working
together
the knight right here on f4 kind of by
himself bishop here on h5 not doing too
much although eventually could take this
pawn here
would like to get the rook down here to
b1 uh but there's just no way to do that
uh because white gets to respond so
queen to c2
stopping the attack queen takes on c4
uh but then rook to e8s and there's a
couple options that black has here if
you exchange
well okay you're just going down
material and you don't have much left
if you don't though king 2 h7 then
you're going to give up a rook in
exchange for
taking some pawns here but knowing that
you're going to be down quite a bit of
material so queen takes here on d5
check queen 2 d2 cannot lose the queen
here that would just be easy victory for
white bishop two
f three check after taking the pawn
king c1 queen over here to f5 and you
can see white's definitely
up a ton immaterial rook here
to e3 stopping this knight coming to
d3 but actually could have just played
queen to d8 because now
if you see knight two d3 check you could
just see king 2
d2 and you can't even take the rook
there on e1 that would be checkmate
queen
2 g8 and then you could see
queen takes here on g7 this is all
because the bishop here on
c3 so at the end of the day this would
be checkmate but
uh heat of the moment you feel like you
have a good position it's madness
carlson always tricky to find the
absolute best moves
i needed to recognize that rook to e3
was not the best move
in the post game commentary uh but
still thought he had a very good
position here so king to b2
knight takes here on a c3 queen takes on
a c3
queen two f4 queen
d3 uh check and then pawn to f5
rook over here to f8 madness carlson
doing a very good job
of continuing to check uh white's king
uh why doing the best job he can trying
to just trade off queens knowing that he
has
two rooks to this bishop uh if he just
swayed off the queens that would be a
pretty easy victory
and then eventually we get to a spot
where white is able to just take this
bishop here
on e4 he has two rooks he can easily
trade a rook for a bishop and then he
doesn't have to worry about
too many threats right here and then it
just becomes a matter of
not making a huge mistake now magnus
crossing
credit to him never stopping the attack
the rest
of the game a lot of players would just
resign knowing that they are down
essentially a rook
magnus carlson continues to play the
rest of the game
and then at the end what i appreciate
from yon kristoff is he ends on such a
beautiful move
queen to h7 check king down here to
g4 and you have forced the trade here
you could
take with your queen a very easy victory
but he plays
rook 2e4 check and you can obviously see
yes the queen can take and the queen
falls and white's left with the queen
cannot move the king anywhere we can
still protect the queen
and so in this case madness crosston
recognizes he's going to lose the queen
no way to continue resigns in this
position
was pretty devastated that he lost
125 games still incredible to think
about
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video uh
even if you haven't been watching the
norway chess 2020
now at least you know some of the
highlights that are going on thank you
guys so much for watching i'll see you
in the next video